[Music]
foreign
thank you foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
okay
who is the Speaker of the House
is it the weaker speaker
Kevin McCarthy
or is it the leader the true leader of
the House Representatives Hakeem
Jeffries
I don't know maybe we'll find out
oh
Matt venmo gatz decides yesterday that
he's gonna go to the house floor
and he's going to bring a vote to vacate
the seat or the the the speaker
get rid of Kevin McCarthy oust him get
out of here
which is hilarious and the reason why is
because apparently there are five
Republicans that are willing to oust
Kevin McCarthy which means
that Kevin McCarthy needs Democrats
he has to have Democrats here to save
his speakership
which is hilarious now
I think that democrats should and will
play absolute full-on 100 politics with
this
Hakeem Jeffrey should make Kevin
McCarthy genuflect to him
and tell Kevin McCarthy yes yes my
friend we will save you we will save you
if you trade us
laughs
ow and what I think that the Democrats
should get in trade is a clean CR
until next September September of 2024.
that's right I said it that is exactly
what the Democrats should trade Kevin
McCarthy here's the reason why I say
this this is just my if I
was leader Jeffries this is what I would
be doing
I would say look
give us a clean CR to September of next
year you vote today on a clean CR you
bring enough of your members to vote for
this clean CR will bring our members to
vote for this clean CR we will get this
whole government shutdown thing out of
the way until next year in September
and we will grant you your wish
let's shake on it
let's shake on it Kev I mean Kevin likes
handshake deals doesn't he
vote on the clean CR
for September of next year and here's
the reason why I do that the reason why
if I'm leader Jeffries the reason why I
punt
this shutdown fight into next year in
September because what is going on next
year right after September what could it
possibly be that we would want to play
politics with a republican threatening
to shut the government down and showing
how truly inept they are oh yes an
election
Democrats
should let them play chicken
with the shutdown next year in September
that's what they should trade to him
that's my thought
that's what I would trade
now I would make it a handshake deal
make Kevin bring the vote to the floor
vote for the clean CR till September of
next year handshake deal and then [__]
him
but the chips fall where they may Kev
you like handshake deals I'll show you a
handshake deal that's what I would do
I mean if the handshake deal works out
and Kevin's favor and he remains speaker
fine whatever I don't give a [__] does
anyone else really care if Kevin
McCarthy is the speaker of the house
he's feckless anyway so who gives a good
God damn if he's the speaker or not
at this point he's not even really the
most powerful person in in Congress
right now Hakeem Jeffries is
to be to be quite honest with you this
morning the most powerful man in
Washington this morning is Hakeem
Jeffries
that's who holds all the power he holds
the power of the democratic caucus and
now this morning he absolutely holds the
Republican caucus I don't know if you've
noticed this morning on Twitter every
single Republican member of the caucus
that Kevin McCarthy can get to tweet I
stand with Kevin
is tweeting it
as Kevin McCarthy begs begs King
Jeffries in private you know that's what
he's doing
because out in front of the camera he's
all butt baking Hakeem Jeffries and the
Democrats to save him here
there's five votes five Republican votes
to get rid
of Kevin McCarthy
Kevin McCarthy has to have Democrats
vote to keep him
there's gonna be a few that are going to
vote not to keep him Hakeem Jeffries
will
do that
but think about this in the space that
we're in
because why why on Earth why on Earth
would Matt gatz want to do this a lot of
people are saying for attention
I highly doubt that Matt Gantz has
plenty of ways to get attention
not to bring some stupid [__] vote to
vacate the speaker
which is a really dumb move for
Republicans even they know it folks
these are the same people who can't
conjure up enough evidence to convince
the country that they're pretending to
impeach Joe Biden did you watch the
[__] hearing the other day
I don't know I don't know if you watch
how much they made fools of themselves
now a lot of people want to say that
that's what you would trade away you
dropped the impeachment and we'll keep
you a speaker [__] that keep trying to
pretend to impeach Joe Biden there's no
one else that it's helping more than
Democrats to what Republicans carry on
with the pretend impeachment fine do
that you're making fools of yourself
not only can you not govern you can't
even impeach someone
okay good luck
good luck with you
but that would be my strategy if I was
speaker Jeffries because this morning
that's literally who is the Speaker of
the House
this morning
it's Jeffries
they've got what 42 more days 42 more
days until this stop Gap
is done that the government will be shut
down right before the holidays folks
right before the holidays oh boy no
better timing for Republicans to really
drop the ball right well do you think
they give a [__]
do you think they care about the
American people in general do you really
think they care enough right before the
holidays
that they would totally screw the
American people
and not do their basic job is to fund
the government that's one of the first
tasks
that the House of Representatives does
is appropriate funds someone said the
other day they legislate well I mean
they're supposed to
but literally literally their number one
task
the bare minimum the bare minimum
work that they do is to appropriate
funds and fund the government
to keep it going
it's like the [__] bare minimum
so legislate is like second on that list
if you can't keep government open you
can't legislate
no
whoo baby
so that's why I say if leader Jeffries
is listening which I don't think
actually leader Jeffries listen to the
show he understands messaging and
narrative almost better than anyone so
he doesn't need to you know hear my
messaging he's very good at it himself
honestly he could do this show better
than I could probably do this show
he's that good at narrative and
messaging
he picked up on the Civil War thing
he knows where the Civil War is
and he knows driving wedges down in
between Republicans is only increasing
his power
and increasing the chance that he will
be speaker in the house next year
because of you and your work that you're
going to do to make sure that you let
the country know and everyone who's
going to vote no
that Republic that Republicans are
derelict in their Duty here
and what better way to to set the
example and set the stage for that then
they'll leave Kevin McCarthy as the
feckless leader of the Republican caucus
who can't even keep the government open
and do it on a handshake
Hakeem Jeffries Kevin McCarthy oh he
[__] loves handshake deals loves them
loves them and honestly if you break the
handshake deal it's no big deal to Kev
Kev oh man he's super familiar with
breaking deals especially handshake
deals
so let's do that
let's do that
oh some people can like Tony you
shouldn't do what they do
ha
ha ha ha
I don't know if you're if you're aware
of the dire state that we're in here
the whole reason why we're here in the
first place is because Kevin McCarthy
traded away his speakership for Donald
Trump's votes
Donald Trump picked out people in the
House of Representatives that were going
to vote against Kevin McCarthy until he
decided that he wanted to vote for him
authoritarianism that got us in this
position in the first place that's what
is the trouble with Congress right now
anyways
it ain't because we the country are
divided it's because them the
Republicans are at civil war with each
other
and they're trying to figure out what
they're going to do with the criminal
dictator and King Mussolini Jesus who
doesn't even know how much mar-a-lago's
work did you see this yesterday he said
I don't know if you know this he's on
Civil Trial right now which is going to
absolutely cut down
the Trump organization like a fresh cut
tree
but he claimed yesterday that Mar-A-Lago
was worth a billion dollars with a B a
billion that lion sank a [__] the Trump
organization said in their own reports
that it was worth 27 million with an m
not a billion with a B this morning this
morning Grandpa walked in the courthouse
and all of a sudden it's worth a billion
and a half dollars
holy [__] you talk about inflation
God damn Mar-A-Lago went for me and
worth a billion yesterday to a billion
and a half today oh that's a sweet
[__] deal
[__] the house that I'm in right now is
worth at least 60 billion dollars
why I mean that's I'm gonna go and tell
the press that it's worth 60 billion
that way they report it that I said that
that way I can say that people are
saying that it's worth 60 billion
dollars and that maybe the bank will
give me a loan
that's the that's the thing that he did
don't you see don't you hate when right
Wingers are like who well he just he
just all he did was just get a mortgage
on this property and and he paid the
mortgage in the interest and the
insurance and blah blah blah yeah well
there's [__] laws in banking
and you can't defraud a bank with the
with the collateral that you're using
for a mortgage
nor can you try to skate on taxes by
misrepresenting
the value of a property you [__]
boneheads
and and trying to get someone to report
something in the media so that you can
say see people are saying so it must be
worth that much is not an appraisal
that's literally what he's trying to do
this more yesterday and today when he's
saying it's worth a billion dollars he's
kidding the press to do his bidding by
getting them to say that it's worth a
billion [__] dollars
now here's how they do it they're like
yeah Trump said it's worth a billion
dollars today and then today they're
going to say it's worth a billion and a
half and he's going to start pointing to
the press and say see they're even
saying that it's worth a billion people
are saying people are saying
but that's the fraud don't you see it
that's the [__] fraud
that's why he's in the situation that
he's in
so keep going dude and yesterday this
thin veiled threats to the [__] judge
and the Attorney General
especially when Trump's strategy and
Trump's attorney strategy was to have a
bench trial yes I said it that was a
strategy so he could whine and [__] and
moan that he didn't get a fair trial
because he didn't have a jury listen a
lot of people were reporting yesterday
and it was confusing
that Alina hamba forgot to check a box
nope that's not the case they checked
the box to have a bench trial they
selected to have a bench trial and it's
not not that the form said hey if you
want the judge to decide check here
that's not what it said
what the box says on the form defile in
court is no jury
it says the words no jury
this is a strategy
this is a [__] strategy
that he's using to be the victim I'm a
victim hey I'm a victim I'm such a
[__] victim
such a whiny little [__]
he is and everyone around him is such
whiny little [__] Elena Haba goes on
the [__] Trader TV news networks
yesterday
to talk about this this unchecked box
and she's kind of right in what she was
saying
like she's like no we didn't miss we
didn't it wasn't a situation where we
missed Miss marked the the form yeah
it's because you didn't want a jury
they intentionally did not want a jury
they did this intentionally that's my
belief
I mean I can't prove it because they're
a [__] bunch of boneheads and they
lie their asses also how the hell are
you going to prove this thing
two reasons two reasons why I believe
that Trump did not want a jury the first
one is so he can whine like a little
[__]
if he lost
that's right he could whine like a
little [__]
because he is a whiny little [__]
oh my God how can anyone who claims that
they're like some kind of tough guy and
[__] think that this guy is their savior
he's such a [__]
he's such a [__] oh my God he's a [__]
oh [__] just his just his utter
existence
just just oozes the word [__]
did you see
I'll get back to the goddamn reason why
here in a minute did you see some of the
pictures of this [__] [__] in the
courthouse holy [__]
he literally has like three hairs on his
head that he's twisting around oh my God
that's this is why it pisses him off
when he can't be in a situation where he
controls where the cameras are in you
know that's why he gets weirded out by
it
that's why he comes out on stage and
stands in a weird spot and just stands
there he doesn't really like turn around
or do anything because he doesn't want
you to see the back of his [__] bald
ass head
as if it matters we know you're bald
dude it's not a [__] secret I mean we
can see the pictures we can see the
light shining off your Dome through the
[__] three hairs that you still got
left that you're twisting around your
head
like a goddamn Tumbleweed okay we can
tell
man
anyways back to the reason why
he wanted a he wanted a bench trial he
did not want a jury number one so he
could [__] number two because the main
reason is he really thought he could use
his words the best words he uh the most
excellent words they're the greatest
words I use the best words he thought
that he could intimidate this judge by
what he said
he really thought that he could he could
pressure this judge and buoy this judge
into doing what he wants him to do
which is declare that he didn't commit
fraud and somehow mar-a-lago's worth a
billion and a half dollars as even if
that's the [__] the biggest fraud in
this case that's not even the biggest
fraud in this case
one of the biggest most obvious frauds
in this case
is that he over-inflated the size of his
[__] apartment in Trump Tower by
three times
twenty thousand square feet
do you know how much 20 000 square feet
is
do you know how much that is
it's a lot of square footage it's a big
[__] building okay
his apartment in Trump Tower his
personal [__] penthouse
in Trump Tower is ten thousand square
feet
and that is an objective number now if
someone's arguing like all right I
actually think it's ten thousand two
hundred but you're calling it ten
thousand I can see how you know people
could get confused
you see what I mean like are you
measuring on the outside or the inside
because that makes a difference when
you're talking about square footage on
buildings like where you're measuring
but this guy's like no it's 30 000 for
sure
and we see the deposition that's been
released of Eric Don Jr and Michael
Cohen
and Michael Cohen is saying what we all
know
this wasn't exactly all about loans and
insurance right which that's the
majority of it the majority of it is is
that he wanted to get high at high high
big huge loans for these properties but
then he would lie about the value how
how much it wasn't worth when he went to
insure it you understand that right okay
let me give it to you in case there's a
couple maggots listening you moglodytes
out there I know you got some hate I
know I got some hate Watchers listening
I had one in my Facebook uh DMS
yesterday they called me a fat [__]
liar
and it end well with them I told them
hey you know I've said eight thanks for
tuning in [__] for brains that's cool by
me I don't give a [__] if you hate watch
me or not I don't care I don't care if
you [__] hate me or you [__] love
to hate me or you love me I don't give a
[__] come watch
honestly like hit the down button or the
thumbs down button just subscribe to
YouTube whatever you do
and go over to Facebook and send me some
DMS I'll [__] dunk on your ass and
post that [__] up on social media as
well
hell just have a little fun with it if
you want to
and here's the thing
Donald Trump if you man gets out there
and listening what he would do
bear with me here what he would do when
he went to get a bank loan on a property
is let's say the property was worth a
hundred thousand dollars let's keep it
even for you you maggots out there that
aren't very good at math we know how you
do with meganomics all right let's say
it's worth a hundred grand right the
property
this building is where the hunter Grand
he would go to the bank and he would be
like no it's worth it's worth 10 million
dollars and I'm not exaggerating because
he's saying that Mar-A-Lago is worth a
billion and a half when it's really
truly only worth 27 million that's what
the Trump organization appraises it at
that's what they say not when I say not
what the judge says the Trump
organization says
so when you have a hundred thousand
dollar billing and say it's worth 10
million dollars that's about the same as
he's doing right now
and he would go to the bank and say this
thing's worth 10 million dollars the
bank's like okay we'll give you a loan
for 8 million then you're Trump why not
right so he gets a loan and then he has
to insure this property but he goes to
the insurance companies like this place
to [__] dump oh my God you should see
it there's [__] roaches and rats
everywhere Don Jr lives here it's a
[__] goddamn dump it's a [__]
crack house if you want to know the
honest truth I mean anywhere Donald
Trump Jr lives is a goddamn crack house
let's face it
so insurance company I'm saying that
this house is only worth this building
is only worth ten thousand dollars
so I want to insure it for ten thousand
so my premiums are really [__] low
that's the fraud
you can't do that that's the [__]
fraud you can't you can't do that
that's against not only [__] banking
laws insurance laws but you'll lose your
business license especially if that
building is a business
whoo but try to get [__] dummies to
understand this stuff you can't you
won't that's why he lied about his
apartment being [__] 30 000 square
foot because he was trying to get money
and then it was probably only 10 square
feet
when he was trying to ensure it
get with the [__] program and pay
attention you moglodytes
it's fraud
he's a liar [__] he duped you
I mean you're fully [__] duped
you're still gonna vote for him aren't
you you still think he's the Mussolini
Jesus don't you
you think he's Gonna Save The Country
Boy it was so great when he was the
president he did so many great things he
gave rich people [__] tax cuts and
that's it that's all I did that's all he
ate rich people task it was fantastic he
put children in cages too which is a
thing that they want by the way I don't
know if you watch Stephen Miller last
night but he's excited about putting
[__] children back in cages
but this is on and on we go on and on we
go and this is why Kevin McCarthy is not
the speaker of the house this morning
Hakeem jeffries's it's because they sold
their soul
to this [__]
dictator wannabe as Mark milley calls
him
boy are we gonna go through the issues
this today guess what it's Tuesday you
know what Tuesday means it's Taco
Tuesday and that's right Texas Paul is
back he's back here on the Tony Michaels
podcast so don't forget to hit the
Subscribe button on YouTube if you're on
Facebook follow us there as well don't
forget we get stars on Facebook people
were people like Tony don't forget
Facebook we're over here guess what
we're only broadcasting in three three
spots now Facebook YouTube and twitch
that's it three spots I'm not I'm not
broadcasting on Twitter anymore we're
going to talk about Twitter and Elon
Musk little right-wing Nazi plan that
he's trying to use to bring down Twitter
I don't think it's gonna work but we'll
see he's throttling Ben Collins this
morning who has outed him with this plan
we'll talk about that with Texas Paul
we're going to talk about Kevin McCarthy
being the weaker speaker and King
Jeffries being the actors actual speaker
and we're going to talk about this Trump
Civil Trial
where tis James is gonna cut down the
Trump organization like a fresh cut tree
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
right after this Texas Paul don't go
anywhere don't touch that dial
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another
momentum we're
[Music]
to the Tony Michaels podcast
now that he's gonna be down maybe two
three four hundred million dollars
depending on what this judge decides
New York I want to give a shout out to
Bart
sent me a shot I'm doing shots today
with Bart thank you Bart for sending uh
money for shots Jaeger shots I want to
thank everyone yesterday who also sent
in the venmo super chats don't forget
you can send me a message on venmo you
just go to the tonymichaels.com that's
right you just go to the Tony
michaels.com look right here you just
hit subscribe at the top you go down you
can send me a shot that's where Bart
sent in a shot
and then venmo Chan here you can also
support me on patreon you're not I'm
gonna I'm gonna I think I'm gonna change
the name of the tip jar I think I'm
gonna make it the swear jar why not you
know this is the you know this is the
place where the [__] guy resides The
Rush Limbaugh the left side might as
well make this the [__] swear jar
right [__] them [__] em [__] em [__] em
[__] them and I'm happy I'm very happy
to tell you that we have someone who
likes curse words every now and again
with us today back in Action Texas Paul
Texas Paul how are you my friend
you gotta unmute your mic
oh hit the unmute button sorry man
you're slurping coffee in your ear while
you're talking about there you go there
you go how are you my friend it's been a
couple times
I am wonderful man I am wonderful
everything's back on track everything's
good glad to have you back here I'm glad
to have you back here I'm glad to have
you back here on the Tony Michaels
podcast as we do on Tuesdays Texas
Paul's Tuesday everyone was wondering
where you're at and I said I just had
some stuff he had to take care of on
Tuesdays he'll be back and he'll be back
in Action so tell me tell me what you
think this morning because my question
is who is the speaker who's The Speaker
of the House Texas Paul who is it this
morning yeah this is uh I'm loving this
brother I'll let me schadenfreude is not
the word man I am loving this by the way
uh thumbs up on the tip jar yeah turning
into the swear jar that oh you think
that you think that'll work yeah yeah
I've been sitting here on the side
listening to the show that is going to
be fantastic
you know I
I I was listening to the Dave Jolly talk
about this the other day and you know he
used to be just solid Republican he's a
solid Republican
he just FL I mean he came out railing
and I have to say I completely agree
with the guy do not save McCarthy for
any reason do not give him a vote not
not a single Democrat
he has been the worst of the worst of
the Republicans you've got they keep
saying well The Radical Republicans well
what's not radical about McCarthy
that is true you know and and there's
there's a good case to be made there
because I I don't know that McCarthy is
a radical but he's a feckless coward so
he's willing to genuflect two radicals
right and he's he's willing to inflict
to Trump and manga but here's the thing
here's the thing is
why not use Kevin McCarthy as a tool
is our little is our little way to save
democracy here that's all my case is
here for Kevin McCarthy or main speaker
because let's face it Kevin McCarthy's
not going to get anything done in the
House of Representatives nor is another
Republican speaker there's not a
republican speaker that is going to be
able to pull together the house
conference with such a slim majority to
do anything that would even be Not Dead
on Arrival in the Senate am I off my
rocker there
you know man I I agree with you 100 I
you know I'm gonna take what you were
talking about if you were if you were
Jefferson uh Hakeem Jeffries what would
you do what would you do I was thinking
about that while you were saying that I
just made a quick list I'd be on the
phone with Tom steyer uh uh Donald
Sussman Mike Bloomberg Dustin Moskowitz
and Reed Hastings from Netflix these are
solid Democratic billionaires that
solidly support the Democratic party I
would be on the phone with them uh
telling them look we need just a handful
across you know back in the 70s and 80s
you had a lot of Republicans that uh
that switched parties you know you got
Shelby from Alabama you've got all this
but there used to be solid Democrats and
they moved to the Republican party I
think we're seeing a time now where the
Republicans are just so freaking insane
let me just do you mind if I read a list
yeah go ahead okay these are Republicans
sitting in Biden districts yep and
there's is there 10 or 12 of them
there's 18. well 17 17 because one one
of them happens to be uh George Santos I
mean wow right yeah right but you got
you got David swalkart Juan sister Monty
uh John Duarte David valadeo Mike Garcia
young Kim Michael Steele Don Bacon Tom
Keane Nicholas yeah anyways you get the
idea there's eight well Mike Mike Lawler
is one of the ones that has been most
vocal especially against uh uh gats uh
Matt gatz he's been the one basically
calling him a petulant child I believe
that's the exact quote last night he
called him a petulant child
um on on on tv Mike Lawler has been kind
of the the voice for these 18 or 17 as
you say
um Republicans who are in Biden Biden
districts meaning districts that Biden
won in 2020. yeah Lawler is in in New
York 17th District he is definitely in a
blue area definitely one that they
should really take a look at Mark
Molinaro Brandon Williams are also in
you've got Lori Chavez dorimer uh that
is in an Oregon district that is
extremely blue you get the point
get with your fundraisers get with your
donors and get with these Republicans
and say look you have a home here and I
will use my power I will make deals to
get you funded you do not have to worry
about a primary challenge you do not
have to worry about a republican coming
along and beating you in the seat
because I will make sure you are well
funded I will be the speaker you will
get on decent uh committees make the
deals
make the damn deals to get these people
to cross over
and in these Republicans even before the
election happens just to show how weak
they are could you imagine rolling into
2024 having flipped Congress I mean so
what you're suggesting what you're
suggesting is is that Hakeem Jeffrey
should leverage his power in a way that
he could get uh a 10 or 12 Republicans
to flip so that way he could be speaker
yeah absolutely that's that's your
that's your pitch there
absolutely absolutely which isn't a bad
idea and the reason why this isn't a
horrible idea is because it eliminates a
lot of problems right and one of the
problems is is that I don't know not
being able to govern like that that that
alone is the biggest problem that we
have in one half
um of the legislative branch right now
in our government is that they
absolutely cannot govern they got Hunter
Biden dick brain um is what they've got
and and that has led them to a place of
nowhere and a place where they can't
even keep their own speaker
um now
to me to me that's not a bad idea but
also I know there's an election coming
up in 2024 we're going to need the
biggest turnout that we possibly have
ever had in history of this country so
uh and I know for sure my my brain goes
to why Americans uh vote and what they
vote for but more importantly why they
vote for something is normally that they
vote against something
um and that is key here so my
um I like the idea of a king Jeffrey's
being speaker but and I think he's going
to have a very good opportunity as long
as we do the work of democracy next year
uh I actually I actually believe that
there's going to be enough Democrats
that Kevin McCarthy's not gonna have to
worry here Hakeem Jeffries is going to
going to deliver enough democrats for
speaker McCarthy to remain speaker now
what what a king Jeffries gets for that
that is the that's the thing that I
think
is on everybody's Minds my preference my
preference for politics and elections as
far as it's concerned and show to show
speaker McCarthy's fecklessness and to
show the Republicans uh uh
not their ability not to govern is to
say I will trade you a clean CR
into September of next year
for to give you I don't know 20 maybe 25
30 Democrats to make sure that you
remain speaker clearly you are main
speaker uh in a in a bipartisan vote now
I don't know here's here's here's
McCarthy he's really he's really this
morning he's begging uh Democrats to
keep him here let's listen to what he
had to say
I get politics I understand where people
are I truly believe though the
institution of the house at the end of
the day
if you throw a speaker out that has 99
of their conference
that kept government open
and paid the troops I think we're in a
really bad place for how we're going to
run Congress so he's begging I mean
that's that's what that is that's
begging Democrats to vote for him I mean
do you think we're in a bad place man I
mean really you think you think we might
be in a little bit of a bad place here
you know I mean
well I mean he is he is the speaker of
the house so it it is um it is telling
that he has to stand there and reflect
on his leader his own leadership uh
because the reason why the reason why
that that Kevin McCarthy had to rely on
Democrats over the weekend to keep
government open at the very last second
like at the very last second is because
he he reneged on his deal with Joe Biden
he's he's a [__] coward and he's a
goddamn liar is what he is and he can't
be trusted I mean that's the problem is
Kevin McCarthy can't be [__] trusted
I wouldn't buy an Apple from the sun
right uh and and Joe Biden did it on a
handshake deal which Joe Biden no
telling how many handshake deals that
Joe Biden has done in his career and no
one has reneged on those handshake deals
probably not Joe Biden on one of them
and that just tells you the kind of
character that Joe Biden has versus uh
Kevin McCarthy and the Republicans but
more than anything more than anything
let me show you this clip here it's in
the same press conference but he is
admitting he's admitting and he knows
that his fate is in the king Jeffrey's
hands
no I I personally am not
you need their help
no um
if five if five Republicans go with
Democrats then I'm out so it's what it's
it's weather but there's five
Republicans that are saying they're
gonna go with Democrats like literally
this morning they're five it's um and I
can bring them up it's it's gats it's
bird [__]
um it's uh uh Eli um what the [__] his
name uh there's five of them there's
five Republicans who have said that they
are going to vote
uh to vacate the seat of speaker now I
want to show you uh leader Jeffries but
we're going to call them speaker
Jeffries today because today on the hill
he's basically the speaker here's leader
Jeffries this morning uh on MSNBC
talking about what he's going to do
leader Jeffries there are many Democrats
as you know who say yeah no we're not
going to help this speaker the one who
opened the floodgates of an impeachment
inquiry and all the other legislation
that you disapprove of they say broke a
budget deal with uh President Biden is
it your sense that there are enough
Democrats who might be willing to just
say hey the the House of Representatives
is working he's going to keep his job
and to vote to support him
well that remains to be seen we do know
that the House of Representatives has
largely been turned over to the most
extreme elements of the house Republican
conference and that's not good for the
American people we'll have to see how
that plays out in the context of this
possible motion to vacate that maybe be
before us either later on today or
tomorrow we do know that as Democrats
look we came to Congress to fight to
make life better for everyday Americans
build a healthy economy put people over
politics but the Republicans have been
fighting each other from the very
beginning we are in the midst of a
republican Civil War and it is
undermining the ability of the Congress
to solve problems on behalf of hard work
and taxpayers and one way or the other
that's going to have to end not
necessarily in the context of what may
be before us this week it just has to
end because it is not
um a productive situation for the
country to find itself in with all of
the challenges that we continue to work
through to try to deal with the problems
facing everyday Americans so there you
go and you can see that the contrast
between Kevin McCarthy just being
absolutely terrified in front of the
microphones at the question of are you
gonna have to get Democrats to vote for
easily yeah I'm definitely going to have
to get Democrats to vote for me and then
the confidence of speaker Jeffries here
because he is the speaker well let's
let's face it in Texas Paul um Hakeem
Jeffries won 14 of the 15 votes for
speaker of the house he literally won
the majority of those votes now not
enough to be the speaker but he won the
majority of those votes 14 out of the 15
times he is the speaker today because he
controls Kevin McCarthy's future uh just
just by the snap of his finger rather
he's going to allow some of his members
to save Kevin McCarthy because let's
face it Democrats actually have a caucus
that is that is a caucus that is working
in Congress and they are working in
concert in Congress we saw that last
week in the hearing where Jim Comer Jim
Q Anon Comer was pretending to impeach
Joe Biden but tell me tell me tell me
why I should believe that Hakeem
Jeffries doesn't control Kevin
McCarthy's future here tell me why I
shouldn't believe that
oh there's there's no reason I could
give you because absolutely Kevin
McCarthy doesn't have the votes to do
this on his own until it comes down to
nut cutting time we're going to see the
same idiocy again it'll be boat after
boat after vote after vote
um he's going to look weak and
idiotic they're going to extract more
radical crap out of him to to move over
because Hakeem Jeffries isn't going to
give him the votes he's just not that's
not our job
that's not what we're here to do we're
not here to elect a republican speaker
that that puts forward one of the most
radical agendas we have ever seen I mean
they're they're having an impeachment
inquiry that's not really an inquiry
because they can't hold the votes
because they don't have the votes right
but they're going to hold this anyways
and then produce no Witnesses I mean
this is insanity meanwhile right now I
just did a video on New Orleans did you
know New Orleans is going to run out of
drinking water at the end of the month
added drinking water yeah yeah we have
had such a little rain in the
Mississippi River Basin that saltwater
is running back up the Mississippi River
and it hits the inlets to New Orleans uh
water treatment plants October 29th
yeah it does Joe Biden has already
declared a state of emergency John Bel
Edwards the Democratic uh governor of
Louisiana is trying to work on it
Republicans are doing [__] all well they
are they well now wait a second I think
that Hunter Biden's [__] probably has a
lot to do with the water down there in
New Orleans I would imagine I would
imagine that fake ass evidence of bribes
that Joe Biden didn't receive probably
has a lot to do a lot to do and you know
what shutting down the government
probably would have helped that problem
too Texas Paul it seems like maybe I'm
wrong and and trustee psychic here says
nut cutting time it sounds like it's nut
cutting time down there in New Orleans
um to get some [__] done but Republicans
do you think they give a [__] about
drinking water in New Orleans they're
much more concerned they're much more
concerned to make sure that they run
they they run a distraction for their
Mussolini Jesus who's about to lose his
entire organize because he's a [__]
fraud and always has been and always
will be they're way more concerned about
their their their Republican Jesus
becoming the nominee and it might be nut
cutting time for that too explain to the
crowd what nut cunning time is I know
what nut cutting time is explain to them
what nut cutting time is
in any situation in any situation uh you
know back look
when you have male calves yeah if you if
you leave the nuts called Bulls they're
called Bulls right well they're male
calves when they're calves you know
right they're not Bulls yet oh not yet
they're bull calves okay they're bull
cats right
but if you leave the nuts on them right
they're pretty much well useless because
you one bull will service
50 cows right you know I mean he's a
he's a horny bastard is what you're
saying so what you do is you run all the
bull caps and all your calves into a
chute you separate out the bull calves
from from the cows and uh you put them
in a in a in a uh head shoot you go back
there you slice the nuts open pull the
balls out cut the nuts off now do you
fry them or did you feed them did you
fry them or did you feed them to the
dogs did you make mountains
Korea Dia is not one of my favorite
dishes
you don't like fried testicles come on
yeah not my favorite you know well let
me tell you something let me tell him
where I'm from there's a difference out
you know there's a there's a town really
close to where I'm from it's called
Olean
and that's what it's called Olean and
they used to have what they called the
annual testicle Festival we'd have the
testifesty every year and you go and
you'd eat you some some fried balls um
but here's the thing here's the thing is
that uh nut gutting nut cutting isn't
pretty either it's not a pretty
processed it's a dirty process we used
to sharpen the old old timer you know
what an Old Timer is the Old Timer
pocket knife we sharpen that some [__]
in the morning before we go do the nut
cutting when it was nut cutting time I
want to thank Lori Lee Lori Lee gave us
around the shot sticks as Paul yeah
that's cool yeah so thanks Laura around
around not cutting just just to finish
the story up the point cutting is that's
the point of no return
those little bull calves once you cut
them nuts off man that's it they are
food that's it they're cattle right
cattle at that point there's nothing
else you could do with them but feed
them out to about 600 pounds and sell
them to a processor that's it there's
the point of no return and we call it we
call them steers right you call them
steers they're steers at that point once
you once you steer them in that
direction they're no longer useful uh so
yeah the the term nut cutting time is is
in any situation where you're at the
point where the votes have to be there
or you know talking's over with it's
time to get busy that's not cutting time
um Susan says testicle Festival yeah the
testifesty I've been missing out you
have been I'm telling you Texas poll
doesn't like them but fried fried bull
balls are good Mountain Oysters as they
call them
um you know and sometimes you can trick
people into thinking they're chicken
nuggets and they eat them like damn
these are these are the best chicken
nuggets I've ever had in my life and
then you tell them what they are and
sometimes they freak out sometimes they
don't but my heart you eat liver all the
opal you know what I mean I eat three of
us you know the the intestines I don't
care man all of that but the balls have
a [__] weird texture that's just I I
don't dig it man I don't dig it well it
happens you should go to a testifesty
sometimes speaking of people who've been
steered and had their balls cut out uh
here's Kevin McCarthy again
um this morning on CNBC but let's see
what he said in this interview he's
making the media rounds let's see what
he said
speaker what are the Democrats asking
you for as as you try to build support I
imagine from Democrats in this case I
imagine they're going to try to drive a
hard bargain you know what they haven't
asked for anything I'm not going to
provide anything and let's just be clear
uh when Nancy Pelosi was the minority
leader she would always come in and she
told Boehner and and Paul uh that she
didn't believe in them utilizing this
how they removed Vayner that she would
always voted down not based upon saving
an individual but based upon what's good
for government what's good for the
institution as a whole and that's the
question has to be are we now in a
situation in our government
that we just provided keeping government
open that we're going to play politics
with how you become speaker if that's
the case then I think we've got real
problems uh you are the problem and
here's the thing he's just begging
Democrats just begging them to save him
it's [__] pathetic if you want to
know the honest truth go ahead baynard
and Paul Ryan didn't face this because
they didn't make the stupid [__] deal
that Kevin McCarthy made that he could
be removed based on the motion from one
individual he made that deal let him
live with it man I mean they're that his
his [__] right there is [__]
Paul Ryan and Boehner never faced this
situation because they were leaders I
didn't agree with them I didn't like
them I don't like their politics I don't
like the [__] they did but they ran
their caucus man McCarthy is trash he's
a weakling he gave up the freaking store
to become speaker because that's all he
ever wanted
screw that guy man screw him well here's
the thing is that the reason why Kevin
McCarthy's in the situation that he's in
and Republicans are in the situation
that they're in where they have to beg
Democrats to save him they have to rely
on Democrats to keep government open to
do the bare minimum of what congress's
job is is because of us and what I mean
by that is us the voters there was no
Red Wave in 2022. it was barely a a pink
spatter that is all it was if it was
that at all it was more in that they
redistrict several districts to make it
to where they could have the slimmest of
the slimmest the majorities and what
Kevin McCarthy had to do is he had to
trade away his speakership to a handful
of dumb sons of [__] in Congress and
I say dumb sons of [__] because
that's exactly what they are and that's
what a king Jeffries laid out this
morning again on Morning Joe so as Kevin
McCarthy is begging speaker Jeffries to
save him listen to what speaker Jeffrey
says about that handful of [__]
front
as part of the chaos the dysfunction the
extremism that we see on the other side
of the islands not one or two
individuals it's the approach that they
have taken to governing and it is
hurting the American people and that's
exactly what and King Jeffrey should
stay fast in that narrative is that
Kevin McCarthy is one of the extremists
because he's done the deal with the
extremists right you are the extremist
well look what he's done man I mean even
if you just don't even look at Marjory
Trader green don't even look at the look
at what bills he's put forward it
doesn't get any more extreme than Kevin
McCarthy you know I don't know why I
can't somebody Tony you educate somebody
educate me as to why this guy is not
labeled an extremist everything he does
is [__] extreme
I mean look at how many twice he shut
down the government you know granted we
didn't hit the shutdown this time
because he panicked at the last minute
because you've got everything that was
going on in New York you know Hawaii's
still not back on its feet and then
you've got this problem in New Orleans
brewing and he didn't want to have to
wear I shut the government down for the
next two and a half three four weeks
when all over the news you know the the
the corporate media Can't Ignore New
Orleans forever I mean this is a real
problem there this is going to be all
over the news and the government's going
to be shut down so just out of sheer
survival is the only reason the gov this
government didn't shut down and he's not
going to stick to his deal on the
Ukraine funding no he's just not no well
you can't be trusted here's here's the
Hakeem Jeffrey said just I think it was
about an hour ago in the halls of
Congress they got him there let's listen
Peter Jeffries the word
this is a serious solemn and sober
moment
house Democrats are going to continue to
put people over politics
and to fight to make life better for
everyday Americans from the very
beginning that has been our objective
and it will continue to be our sole
Focus delivering for the American people
we encourage our Republican colleagues
who claim to be more traditional
to break from the extremists in the
chaos in the dysfunction in the
extremism we are ready willing and able
to work together with our Republican
colleagues but it is on them
to join us to move to Congress and the
country forward heavy McCarthy I don't I
don't know if anyone out there knows who
King Jeffries is I I talk about him on
the show a lot and the reason why is the
king Jeffries is going to be as far as
I'm concerned
um one of the best speakers and he will
be the next speaker and I actually
believe that we do our job as the
pro-democracy Coalition Hakeem Jeffries
will be one of the longest serving uh
speakers in our modern history I
actually believe that if we do our job
as the pro-democracy Coalition get off
our answers and really engage in
democracy I believe that King Jeffries
can show leadership can show the
American people and prove to them that
it doesn't matter Republican or Democrat
that [__] doesn't matter it matters if
you elect people who go and do the job
of Congress and one of the [__] jobs
of Congress is the first job and it's
the least difficult job is to
appropriate funds and keep that [__]
open to keep the [__] open if you can't
keep government open you don't deserve
to govern at all period that's how it
works and they can't even seem to do
that they can't even seem to do that so
um here's uh
don't stop man that's yeah well I mean I
mean uh you know state governments all
all over the country that is the the 99
of their focus is 99 of their function
in state houses is to actually just
develop a budget because States can't
run a deficit like the federal
government can
um so that's that's actually where a lot
of these folks who run for United States
Congress actually come from they come
from these State houses and what that's
those State houses do is teach them how
to legislate and how to appropriate
funds and come up with a budget
um Republicans complain and [__] and
moan and and and project that Democrats
don't do a budget Democrats spend too
much money and blah blah blah blah
[__] blah all it is is last year all
it is is [__] when the reality is
when it comes down to it just like on on
the in the weekend it all it takes
Democrats it takes Democrats people who
are serious about the American people
people are serious about their jobs
people are serious policy makers and
want want to legislate for the American
people that sent them there are the only
ones that can keep government open
because they are the ones who actually
believe in the work of the people that's
that's the thing
um you know I'm gonna I'm gonna tell you
the number one reason Hakeem Jeffries is
going to be such a successful speaker is
he is not a radical he's not an
ideologue he's a he's pragmatic and I
will tell you people don't like to hear
this because people don't like to make
deals Hakeem Jeffries will eat a turd
to make a good deal for the American
people he will he will make those deals
behind the scenes that says okay you
want this bill passed and it's against
our agenda
but he said okay we'll get your bill
through but you give me X Y and Z over
here and get it done
and he'll get his X Y and Z before he
eats that turd but then he will stand
behind his word and he will do it and
people will scream they're like I cannot
believe the Democrats did this back on
you know December 19
2022 they passed this bill that is not
part of our agenda
but it was to make a deal for the
greater good and Hakeem will do that and
he has the strength he has the Charisma
he has the ability he has more Charisma
than Nancy Pelosi did he absolutely you
know I and I think I think a lot of
people don't um you know they're gonna
knock me for saying this probably but
Nancy Pelosi is one of the most
effective speaker of the house that
we've had in our modern history she is
the most effective and and I I sincerely
mean that word effective she's a
horrible politician horrible she's not
good at retail politics she's a damn
good fundraiser she's a damn good leader
and she knows the rules of the house
better than any [__] member that I've
seen probably probably since the 1980s
right and that that is that is the most
important thing about Nancy Pelosi and
that's the reason why she was very very
very effective and Greg says here Nina
Turner hates Jeffrey that's because Nina
Turner is a [__] idiot Nina Turner is
a [__] idiot and you need to stop
listening to tyt and Nina Turner if you
want to know the answer if you want
Democrats you want democracy to win in
this win in this country and you stop
listening that [__] garbage and need
Turner you start listening to people who
are pragmatic like like Texas Paul are
saying that King Jeffrey is willing to
eat a turd for the American people Nina
Nina Turner Nina Turner doesn't know
what a turd is if you want to know the
honest truth speaking of people who know
how to eat turds and [__] do the work
of Congress here's a guy Adam Schiff I
wonder if Kevin McCarthy is really
regretting I'm going to show you this
clip deck as well I wonder if he's
really regretting that he totally
[__] he totally [__] he totally
[__] [__] at him [__] when Kevin
McCarthy knows he's from the same
goddamn delegation of the State of
California he knows how serious Adam
Schiff is about his work he knows how
good he is at his work anybody doesn't
agree with him I wonder if he's
regretting it now let's listen to Adam
Schiff give him give Kevin a little bit
of regret here being in the mood in
there uh you know I don't want to uh
uh discuss internal caucus but uh I can
tell you my own view which is
Kevin McCarthy's not trustworthy we
don't trust them they're on conferences
doesn't trust him uh we've just lurched
from crisis to crisis with him as
Speaker
and uh they need to choose someone that
has the ability to govern because it's
not him uh and we don't feel
um
that it's in the best interest of the
country to have the House of
Representative continue to learn from
crisis to crisis so I hope they can
choose someone that has the capability
of at least
getting us uh into more productive
session in the house but clearly it's
not kept McCarthy you predict that Kevin
McCarthy will not be the speaker by the
end of today well I don't know where the
Republican votes are
um but it's certainly my feeling that
democrats should I want to tell you he
knows exactly where the Republicans
votes are that smirk he knows exactly
where they're but let's keep going yeah
um enable uh such an untrustworthy
partner as Kevin McCarthy
oh yeah
oh yeah my ass so [__] him
[__] him how about how about Kevin
McCarthy get go jump off a [__]
Bridge how about that that's the kind of
[__] that I'm talking about though could
you ever imagine Hakeem Jeffries he's a
serious man
could you ever imagine him just
censoring somebody in the Republican
Party
for nothing
I mean just because you know he wanted
to to please some Democrats you know uh
some some people out here pissed off
calling for a little blood does that
Hakeem Jeffries doesn't give a [__]
about that he's not going to do that
he's not going to play circus games in
the house I mean if you're looking for
partisan circus [__] Hakeem Jeffries
is not your guy he is not he's a very
very
serious man and he I mean he he knows
how to get his agenda through he hell he
trained he watched Nancy Pelosi you know
Nancy Pelosi could move legislation like
nobody you've ever seen she could make
the back room deals she understood how
it worked man she was really really good
at that stuff and he sat there right
behind her you know as one of her
lieutenants and just soaked it all in
that's the kind of guy he is he is not
one you know he's not a Kevin McCarthy
he's not there's there's no comparison
between the two well I mean the
Democrats have a lot of serious people
on their side and and the reason why is
because they truly believe in the work
of government and they believe in the
work of the people uh Jim McGovern is
another one here he is on the house
floor speaking speaking about who is the
speaker and who is going to be the
speaker let's listen in Republicans
continue to blindly come down here and
support these hateful policies and vote
for them Time After Time After Time and
I just hope that the next speaker
whoever that may be and maybe we'll find
out today I hope whoever that may be
will do a better job of preventing this
garbage from coming to the floor but
looking at the Republican party in 2023
gentleman's time has expired and there's
another fight in the messaging and the
narrative folks I don't know if you know
this but you know this [__] that
Democrats are in disarray and been in
disarray and they don't they got it's a
bunch a party of old people and all that
[__] that's all [__] I showed you a
video yesterday of Jasmine Crockett
um after her
didn't you love that in the [__] when
she said in the [__] man I was just
[__] pumped I was [__] bummed like
finally someone [__] who says the
[__] that needs to be said in front of
these sons of [__] but here's the
thing Jasmine Crockett laid out on MSNBC
in an interview she said look we got a
deep ass bench and not only do we have a
deep bench they're [__] smart and
they're willing to govern and we're
willing to work as a team to have a
strategy to win that's the difference
that's the difference between the
Democratic party today and the
Democratic Party 10 years ago as
Democratic party knows democracy is on
the line and they know they have to have
a strategy and a team to win
um even even with the most Progressive
of the progressive here is um uh here we
have on Jay pal here let's bring this up
let's see how she's gonna vote they are
destroying Orange institutions
we are not voting in any way that would
have saved Beaker McCarthy so either
present or voting again this does impact
Democrats in a sense right I mean you
guys are trying to fund the government
you're trying to pass the farm bill
you're trying to pass Democratic problem
as much as anybody out here might want
to make it a democratic problem this is
not a democratic problem this is a
republican problem they supposedly have
the majority they should be able to pick
their own speaker our speaker is Hakeem
Jeffries it always has been it was for
15 rounds it will continue to be so does
that mean you hear that just nobody
trusts Kevin McCarthy who trust Kevin
McCarthy nobody trusts Kevin McCarthy
and why should we he has broken his
commitment over and over again and it's
not just the deal with President Biden
it's not just the Ukraine funding which
apparently was also a deal but then it
wasn't a deal on you know unless we
secure the Border it's also going back
to January 6th and I think for a lot of
us we
we were here it is still deeply
emotional for us because it is about our
country it's about why we came to
Congress and Kevin McCarthy stood on the
house floor and said one thing and then
talked to Donald Trump and immediately
did something else he has supported the
insurrectionist president that enabled
January 6 to happen and tried to
obstruct the peaceful transfer of power
so there are a lot of reasons to not
trust Kevin McCarthy
you could probably go back before
January 6 but certainly January 6th uh
was was a really key example and the
most recent history of how he's governed
as speaker is another example and there
you have it there you have it even the
most Progressive Texas poll are like
[__] Kevin McCarthy we won a king
Jeffries just like you said a king
Jeffries is no extremists King Jeffries
is not a Democratic Socialist he's not a
Bernie bro but he's attracting the most
Progressive members to say we support
him as speed brute because he's a
[__] leader he's a [__] leader and
people trust him and that's the
difference in Democrats and Republicans
because my my view of it here and and
really we're getting down to the
nitty-gritty here on who's going to be
the speaker if they vacate this seat but
here's the thing it doesn't matter what
Republican it is it does not matter
Texas Paul Republican it is they cannot
be trusted and they won't be trusted
that is the key that is the Ultimate key
here for this um she brought up a good
point and I want to Pivot here while she
run up this point away from who's going
to be the speaker because what more news
on that tomorrow depending on what kind
of action comes out of the House of
Representatives today and what kind of
deals are struck between Hakeem Jeffries
and the weaker speaker Kevin McChicken
but here's the thing she called Donald
Trump
the insurrectionist president
insurrectionist that is [__]
hilarious it is great did you see this
morning that Donald Trump went from
yesterday that Mar-A-Lago was worth one
billion dollars which is laughable to
this morning he said it's worth one and
a half billion let me show you this clip
this is this is hilarious
so he says he says yesterday is worth a
billion and overnight Texas Paul I guess
inflation is just going crazy in this
country your house has got to be worth
at least three times as much as it was
yesterday because apparently inflation
is just real estate inflation is just
taken off overnight and now Mar-A-Lago
went from 1 billion to a billion and a
half dollars oh my [__] god this guy
can't keep his head on Street it is
yeah you know back when Donald Trump
bought this place part of the deal he
made with Palm Beach County was that
most of it was going to go into a
conservation easement where he cannot
develop it at all he's got to maintain
it exactly as it is
when you weigh into when people that
actually value these properties for a
living value Mar-A-Lago you know you
can't do what Eric did which is going on
and compared to a bunch of single single
family dwellings that can be rezoned you
can't rezone Mar-A-Lago you you can't it
is a historical uh uh site you cannot
rezone it so when his valuation of the
property is done by people that actually
do it for a living they come out with a
value today of about 70 million dollars
okay that's what they actually value it
at because it's got an annual revenue of
about 25 million dollars
but you cannot rezone it you cannot
change it the maintenance costs are
astronomical on this property because
part of the deal he made because he
couldn't afford the taxes on it when he
bought it it was you know the part of
the deal he made to allow him to make
money off of it to actually be able to
afford to live there was that he would
be able to convert it to a club that
deal made with Palm Beach county is in
effect today he cannot develop it he
cannot change it that's why that's why
well that's why he's got to go to bed
Minster every few months because he
can't live there permanently because
that's part of the deal too that it's
not a permanent residence so he
literally has to pick pack his his top
secret documents that he stole in boxes
and taking the Bedminster so he can wave
him around and show people there so
that's why he's got well and he's got to
bury him in the you know the uh at the
eighth hole in his his ex-wife's um his
ex-wife's um uh grave there he's going
to bury documents in there but anyways
then it's not you know I digress from
that but the point is that's why he's
going to go to bed Bedminster because he
can't even live there permanently
because it is a club it's not a house
and you nailed it in the beginning when
you were talking about the this was no
oh I accidentally forgot to check the
box to ask for a jury trial I've been
screaming this from the beginning that's
been all over social media that is crap
at any point prior to this chart they
didn't walk into this trial and say oh
where's the jury we thought we were
going to have a jury right no [__]
they've noticed for weeks exactly they
asked for this to happen for one reason
primarily
if a juror and they know they're going
to lose they know they're going to lose
because exactly what you're talking
about they they show the loan
applications that show none of the
conservation easement on it didn't show
none of the restrictions that would blow
their valuation out of the water it's a
documents case you walk up you open the
books you show the jury
and that's it the case is over there's
no there's no circumstantial evidence
they're going to lose they know it
they've lost already
it's fraud it's obvious fraud well
England's already rule against them on
the front right they've lost already but
it's one guy it's not a jury of 12. the
people just take those guilty verdicts
and say okay yeah enough people listen
to this if it's one guy and ingrown he
looks weird man he looks like Doc Brown
from Back to the Future he does they
know this it's like the wish.com it's
like the wish.com uh Doc Brown yeah yeah
but he they know they can attack him
right and they can go after him and
that's the whole strategy behind this
isn't that they don't know they're gonna
lose it's this how bad do we come out of
this are we going to maintain is your
crazy ass Papa still going to be sending
him money after this trial
if they go to a jury trial nope if they
if if it's just a bench trial and anger
on rules against them you know and finds
him they can still say it's all a lie
three all of them a jury trial they
didn't give him a jury well here's
here's in this uh just moments ago asked
and they asked him if he's gonna
actually I hope he testifies oh my God I
want this guy to get up on the stand I
want them to [__] depose him for
hours and hours and hours but watch
watch as he says he'll if he'll take
this then
every time I will be I think it's going
very well
everybody was given Financial State
through some financial statements are
extremely strong
yes it's a much more valuable as opposed
to less valuable than or in the
statements you know you know I notice in
all these and all and let me back it up
just a bit here to give you this freeze
frame look at Alina hamba how worried
she looks and look at Chris case this is
Chris case this is the lawyer that he's
already paid all his money to up front
Chris guy says every single nickel that
Donald Trump owes him already and he is
just happy as a lark isn't he yeah he is
so happy and Elena have a look so
[__] worried I think that's that
that's a beautiful picture to me you
know what I mean you know what I mean
and Chris Christ is no idiot he's no no
he didn't know he's an actual attorney
he's an actual attorney he's one of the
only ones that that actually does a
turning uh in the Trump World
and he knew prior to this trial he was
not surprised that this was a bench
hearing you know and and he knows that
you can request you know if you're
having a jury trial and you draw a judge
that's really favorable to you you can
go to and file a motion and say you know
what I would rather just have a bench
trial it's not like once this decision
is made it can't be undone you know I
mean they do it all the time they switch
from a bench trial to a jury trial and
from a jury trial to a bench trial
they don't deny people that opportunity
this is just a load of horseshit just so
that they can attack judge Inger on I
mean well let me let me show you let me
give you the receipt here here's the
clip and then here's the actual copy of
the form the the note of issue and you
can see so it's not it's not that uh the
lawyers Mark the wrong box or forgot to
check a box they check the box that says
without jury they do not want a jury
they selected no jury here watch this
you know we're not entitled to a jury
which is pretty unusual in the United
States of America so
you think it's very unfair that I don't
have a jury but I want to address this
one common uh misconception in the press
and unfortunately it just keeps getting
repeated which is that we have this
great option to have a box checked for a
jury no we didn't have yes they did they
did have the opportunity to have a jury
but they selected to not have a jury
intention and again I I go ahead I don't
know if you want to play that again but
the audio didn't come through yeah it
did it's uh the audio is really low on
that one trial without jury they
selected that yeah here here is here is
the form now I will tell you let me back
it up see it right here see how it says
a trial by jury demanded and and it says
of all issues of issues specified below
or attached you're in meaning that in
this court in this court you can ask for
a jury to hear all the all the issues
are all the charges as it were against
the defendant or part of them you can
ask for a a jury to do select certain
ones and then a bench trial for the
other ones they selected no jury none
and again it is the reason that you're
saying is that they want they Donald
Trump wants to be able to intimidate one
person
that's what he wants he wants the
ability to intimidate one person and and
that's and that's his strategy is to see
if he can bully this judge into making
the best decision for Donald Trump now
here's the thing the other reason that I
believe is so he can win [__] and moan
and whine like a little child that I
didn't get a trial how do you get a
truck oh it's so unfair to me oh it's so
unfair I got cheated what kind of what
kind of country is this this is such a
[__] that I don't get a trial that
that sort of [__] that's the reason
brother you're absolutely right he's
already doing it he's been there's video
clips of him doing it why wasn't there a
jewelry everybody's entitled to a
jewelry I didn't have a jury well you
didn't have Jerry because you didn't
want one because you wanted to attach
the freaking judge what do you think
you're bullshitting you're not
bullshitting anybody well did you know
go ahead go ahead
did you see that Ivanka went under the
bus well she is going to go under the
bus here because I actually believe
that's one of the reasons why she's not
on she's not on this judgment and uh I
believe that she's the one who turned on
him but here's here's what here's what
I'll tell you is that
um the the other thing about the
intimidating the judge I don't think
that's going to work out for Donald
Trump the way that he wants
um and everyone's talking about the
judge how he's smiling in the video did
you see the video where he's smiling I
might be able to show that but he's
smiling in the video and everyone's like
oh he's such an ass and I was like I
took that as he's having fun I mean he's
running the court it's a civil court
it's not criminal he doesn't have to put
anybody in jail or anything this guy
doesn't this judge does not have to jail
people he only does civil trials in this
court he that's all that this judge does
is handle civil trials he doesn't put
people in jail
um but it's kind of funny though
and that Donald Trump is attacking this
judge and that that ranking member of
the Judiciary Committee in the Senate
Lindsey Graham lady G thinks that the
way out of this for Donald Trump and I
[__] you not he said this on any
landline let me show you this he thinks
the way out of this for Donald Trump is
to become president and I don't I guess
execute the judge I mean he wants to
execute Mark milley I have no idea what
Lindsey Graham's talking about here
honestly Lindsey Graham should resign
his ranking member's seat on the
committee he should be stripped of all
his committee assignments and he should
consider resigning his United States
Senate seat for this statement in public
alone listen to this and we're not going
to let New York get away with this if
you think
how do you stop a job he wins the
primary he gets to be president again
this judge is a joke
who got defrauded nobody everybody who
was the victim
so there Lindsey Graham is advocating
for Donald Trump to I don't know execute
the judge I mean the weird part is is
that not only does the president United
States not have any say over who's a
judge and who's not they nominate some
judges and the Senate confirms them so a
president doesn't actually get to say uh
who has what judge and what judge can do
what that the actual the Congress has
that ability and the Senate has that
ability that's the check and balance
there but here's the thing if Lindsey
Graham wants the president to have the
power to tell a judge to [__] off no
matter what judge it is well why are we
talking about Hunter Biden pleading not
guilty this morning what are we why are
we doing that obviously Lindsey Graham
wants unilateral power for the president
United States to tell anyone who is
Prosecuting him or his family to tell
them to [__] off and maybe he just wants
them to execute him like Donald Trump
wants to execute mark really I'm not
making this [__] up I'm not saying
anything that's crazy and out there and
hyperbolic Donald Trump has said he
wants to execute generals what makes me
think what would make me think that a
dissenting judge who makes a dissenting
opinion of their Mussolini Jesus that
they don't want them executed that's
that's where we're at isn't it Lindsay
isn't it lady G I think I think Chuck
Schumer should really call into question
all of Lindsey Graham's committee
assignments and ask him to resign I mean
if we're asking Bob Menendez to resign
over some stuff over some gold bars we
definitely should ask Lindsey Graham to
resign because he doesn't understand how
judges and the judicial branch of our
government work
no you're absolutely right and and I
tell you what I'll answer to Lindsey
Graham's question yeah go ahead who got
it well Banks don't have infinite amount
of money they have to do an Actuarial
analysis analysis on the loans that they
lend out the risks to those loans you
know it's a science man it is not just
they throw darts at a freaking wall it
is a science there were people filing
for loans that did not get their loans
because the bank only has x amount of
resources to loan out only so much risk
they can assume so people that could
have could have gotten loans with that
institution didn't that's the first
group that got defrauded the second
group that got defrauded was the backers
that are actually underwriting these
loans because Donald Trump repeatedly
had to refinance and restructure these
loans because he couldn't make the
freaking payments and those creditors
all got hurt they all took a haircut on
this those are the other people the
people that invested behind those
creditors got hurt third was the
taxpayers because we ensure those Banks
and if that bank goes in solvent we're
on the hook for that and they took risks
that were not acceptable because Donald
Trump lied that's who got defrauded
everybody in the freaking country and
everybody that was filing for a loan
that didn't get one because they didn't
you know the Actuarial analysis the the
bean counters couldn't fit it together
on on the the sheets they just couldn't
do it they're the people that got
screwed and you know who doesn't give a
[__] about them Lindsey Graham doesn't
give one [__] about any of them it's
just it's just that it's it's just very
telling that he and Rich that he's on
the Judiciary Committee and he's calling
for a president or someone to become the
president so he can get rid of a judge
it's [__] wild stuff speaking of wild
stuff uh um the Five on Fox news last
night Jessica always bringing the facts
over there uh to uh you know put a put a
peppermint in the fox breath crew um but
here for anyone out there who has Fox
breath now here's Jessica with the facts
on how much Mar Lagos with watch this
2015 and 26 seen over doing things like
this he told everybody I'm the guy that
can fix the code because I'm the one
that knows every loophole and I've been
taking advantage of them so we all knew
this was happening to the Mar-A-Lago
point and down the street there's this
53 million dollar home but it is a
private home whereas Mar-A-Lago is
registered and for good reason because
it's a club where you can go and party
and you can stay as an income producing
club which is taxed and treated
differently this also isn't the
appraisal of just the County Commission
or whatever this is what the Trump
organization said it was worth in 2020
they self-reported that it was worth 27
million dollars and now he's going
around screaming that they're framing
him then your own company framed you and
that's exactly right and I don't know
how else to put the facts uh Jessica
does a great job and again she's really
bringing the facts to the audience that
has facts Fox breath excuse me not facts
breath Fox breath uh over there on Fox
news but that's that's really that's
really the skinny here is that it
doesn't matter what Donald Trump says in
front of cameras that mar-a-longo's
worth it does not matter that doesn't
[__] matter it doesn't matter that he
lies his ass off in front of cameras it
doesn't matter what matters is what you
said what's on the paper what's on the
[__] paper it doesn't matter what he
says folks it does not matter it and
really it doesn't matter in his Civil
Trial or his criminal trials what he
says and the lies that he tells out in
front of a camera what matters is what
the facts are and I love that Jessica
brings the facts because that's how the
judge came to the determination that it
was worth 18 between 18 and 27 million
because that's what the Trump
organization said it was probably worth
the Trump organization
it's crazy yeah exactly you can go back
to the minutes of the here or the the
record of the the hearing and he does
not assign a valuation he just reads off
their their own valuation you know with
the Palm Beach County tax assessor and
says okay you said it was worth this
much that's it I mean and and then you
get Donald Trump standing out front
lying his ass off we were to lie to jury
and they said Mar-A-Lago is only worth
18 million dollars it's worth way more
than that and not a single freaking
reporter from the corporate media did
one [__] and thing that you and I do
which is sit here and say well okay then
why did you value it at 18 million
dollars you lion [__]
who asked that question
well I think I think the judge is going
to ask that question now that they've
asked for a bench trial uh speaking of
Donald Trump Running Scared
uh his his senior advisors on his 2024
campaign uh yesterday released a
statement on the uh the debates that are
about to happen
he's terrified he's terrified that he's
going to lose the primary here Texas
Paul because he knows it's his only way
out of this he says the their statement
is this the Republican National
Committee should immediately cancel the
upcoming debate in Miami and and all
future debates in order to refocus its
Manpower money on preventing Democrats
efforts to steal the 2024 election
anything less among with other reasons
not to cancel our our and admission to
the grant streets that their concerns
about voter Integrity are not taken
seriously and the national Republicans
are more concerned about helping Joe
Biden than ensuring a safe and secure
election literally Donald Trump is
saying the party that he's running in is
out to help Joe Biden win now I'm not
going to say that that's true or false
because honestly I could see a lot of
Republicans inside the RNC working their
asses off to make sure Donald Trump
loses and the reason why is because they
understand the risk of Donald Trump
loses that they'll lose their party
their party is dead Donald Trump has
killed it and if he wins it'll be even
more of a of a death toll for them
um you know that's why Chris Christie's
doing it he ain't doing it no but Chris
Christie's never going to be president
you know that you know he's doing this
for that very reason he is trying to
save his party that's it you know you're
spot on with that 100 it's just all over
the place you can see these Republicans
that you know I don't agree with in any
way shape or form I think they're
incorrigible horrible human beings but
they're at least they're not
blind yeah
well here's the thing is that what is
terrifying Republicans right now is of
their own doing
um they always do this they always they
always do some [__] and it gets them
you know gets them all riled up gets
their base all riled up and then they
realize oh [__] that's not gonna work
out that great
um one example of this is RFK Jr RFK Jr
is entering back into the news
um and it's not because RFK Jr is going
to be the president of the United States
okay it is because right-wingers propped
up and made the right-wing in cells love
RFK Jr because he's an anti-vaxxer okay
this is what they did here's here's
here's one of my Twitter spaces pal DC
drain Drano Rogaine here now uh DC
drainer I was in a Twitter space with
him he's a [__] idiot Trump always
read truce him or whatever it's called
on fraud social
um I was in a space with DC journal and
I told him this I said your delusion
your and manga's delusion about Trump
and about how our country is and will be
is going to be the downfall of trump and
their delusion always leads them down
the stupid path one of the stupid paths
was to prop up RFK Jr because they had
this dumb idea that they thought they
could primary Joe Biden which is not a
thing I told you it was not a thing I
told you that there's not going to be a
challenger to the incumbent President
Joe Biden no one tyt didn't listen to me
because they're a bunch of dumb bucks
like Nina Turner and tytr because they
they propagate lies they propagate
misinformation and they're [__] lying
to you to get you to believe stupid [__]
the same way DC Drano does here and they
propped up RFK Jr here's what DC Drano
now believes today about RFK Jr since
RFK Jr seems to be seeking out uh uh of
funding to run an independent campaign
here's what he says I know people will
disagree on rather or how much RFK
running third party hurts Trump
I think we can all agree on one thing
though it's time to stop highlighting
rfk's positives I'm guilty of that and
take accountability and start amplifying
his negatives his favorables are way too
high especially among conservatives
and they think he's a [__] Democrat
this is hilarious people need to be
reminded that he's a pro-choice
pro-climate change anti-gun leftist well
it's too late now you [__] idiot it's
too late now because you people have
already propagated that RFK JR could win
you did that you made this bed now
you're gonna [__] sleep in it I'm
here to tell you folks that you as
pro-democracy Coalition should not worry
one bit if RFK Jr runs as an independent
if he gets on half the tickets in this
country and the reason why RFK Juniors
was not sold to the pro-democracy
Coalition as an alternative RFK Jr was
sold by Steve Bannon to create this
narrative that Joe Biden wouldn't debate
someone that he's scared and he's feeble
and the Democrats are trying to protect
him what they didn't count on is RFK Jr
using his anti-vaxx [__] to to amass
a huge internet in cell Army that now
RFK Jr believes his own [__] and
believes that he can win as an
independent and he's going to go
juice that in-cell internet Army
to now try to get votes which he'll only
take away votes from anti-baxters folks
remember that and remember it good that
the politics of RFK Jr was never
intended to hurt Joe Biden it was only
intended to make Joe Biden look weak
which he's not and that is why they
always fail is because they they [__]
throw these rakes out and they [__]
jump on them as hard as they can
um Texas Paul are you going to vote for
RFK Jr I mean yeah no I don't give a
damn what scabby mcfuck stick says I
don't care I don't care what scabby
mcfuckstick says I don't I do not care
Bannon is an idiot Bannon took the name
Kennedy and thought Oh Democrats will
love the son of a [__] they will love
him he's a Kennedy man he's a Kennedy
he'll he'll peel off so many Democratic
votes we're going to win this easy and
everybody you know the Democratic
Department don't you feel it man the
Democratic party has changed you know
back back in 2016 we were different you
know we were that oh you only gave me 93
of what I wanted therefore you must go
because that seven percent was
everything to me the Democratic party
now today is is fog fascism
and they they are not playing this game
the Democratic party normally would be
screaming its guts out
you're not going to have debates you're
not going to have a primary oh my God no
the Democratic party today is [__] that
noise we've got our candidate we know
who we're running we will weaken in
Bernie that [__] if we have to
if Joe Biden passed away today that I
guarantee you they would stuff him put
sunglasses on him and that [__]
would win the next election
I promise you well you know I I've been
getting a lot of flack for saying that
Donald or Donald Trump is going to get
trounced by Joe Biden there's no
question in my mind about it it's just a
numbers game the Democrats know where
all these votes are
um they know and they know why they want
Trump to be the nominee it's very clear
um but DC Drano here doesn't seem to
quite understand or maybe he's getting
the drift here of why Trump is so
problematic in as their dear leader he
says here to be clear most concern is
highlighting rfk's positives did so in
an attempt to boost his chances in the
Democratic primary against Biden now
either DC Drano
is lying there or he is a complete utter
[__] idiot and does not know how
Democratic primaries work and I was
telling everyone this that if you think
that Joe Biden is going to have any kind
of primary Challenger you do not know
how the Democratic primary process works
for a presidential candidate you just
don't understand there is super
delegates did they change after uh
Bernie and Hillary in 2016 yes but not
enough to sway it not enough to sway it
the super delegates are the ones who
choose the Canon and there's no [__]
way on Earth in this [__] universe
that the Democratic superdelegates were
going to choose RFK Jr as their nominee
these are card holding party members and
they weren't going to choose RFK now DC
drainer goes on because he doesn't
understand how Democratic primaries work
because this guy's a [__] for brains he
says the enemy of my enemy is the quote
right
but he goes on to lament but now that
he's likely running as an independent
they really didn't count on uh RFK Jr
buying his own [__] now that he's
likely running as an independent the
calculus has changed and we're adapting
accordingly listen to this folks oh RFK
was a plant oh my God RFK was a plant
like we said he [__] was to help
Trump and what happened was is RFK is a
Kennedy he has access to huge amounts of
money and now he can get some of that
money from donors to run an independent
campaign and now they're scared because
they know what they did what they did
was is they lied to their [__] base
about RFK Jr they [__] you [__]
lied Rogaine you piece of trash and
that's that's the reason why Maga should
[__] absolutely walk away from these
jackasses walk away from them today
tomorrow and next week and next year and
keep walking away from them is because
cause they're [__] dope they're
[__] duping you they're duping you
into believing this dumb ass [__] about
politics that has nothing to do with the
[__] truth and at the end of the day
it comes back to bite you in the ass you
the voter you the taxpayer you being the
person who's in the government it bites
you in the ass their lies bite you in
the ass not them so start punishing them
okay like DC Drano here this piece of
[__] garbage Jesus Christ I know how
many times I gotta say it but you know
we'll get there all right so that's my
rant about RFK and I had to bring that
up that they're terrified and this is
all in the right wing space Charlie Kirk
can't stop [__] talking about it
Benny Johnson can't stop talking about
it they're terrified that RFK Jr is
going to run honestly if Democrats want
to absolutely [__] just throw
wrenches in the right wing system start
donating to RFK Jr for him to run an
independent campaign that [__]
will absolutely destroy them on balance
in in red States he's going to destroy
Trump on balance in red States go ahead
there are enough people in the
Republican party that are becoming
disaffected radicals that that he will
get funding from the anti-vaxxers it
absolutely will he is going to be a
third party candidate he really is
there's nothing we can do about it and
and but it doesn't hurt like you said it
does not hurt us and I will blow my own
horn here Tony because of you because of
me because of Hal Sparks because of the
Midas Brothers everybody's been getting
out there and it's planning all of this
[__] to people that don't follow
politics man if there's a lot of people
that follow us that don't normally
follow politics they just like our style
they like the way we do things and
you're making a huge [__] difference
man huge people are not saying oh it's a
Kennedy no they listen to what you said
this guy is a freaking [__]
he is a self-opportunist [__] put
forward by by scabby mcfuckstick to try
to peel off Democratic votes and they
are absolutely dying that none of it
ever caught on with the Democratic party
because of us not because of the
mainstream media you remember the
freaking corporate media they loved
Robert oh oh yeah because he's a
candidate because he's a Kennedy oh yeah
yeah they love that guy well you know
and and to Robert Kennedy's credit he's
been a climate chain activist for the
majority of his life but he took a wild
turn with the vaccine and that's what
and that's what is going to get Trump in
trouble it's going to get right-wingers
in trouble is because they were like oh
look there's a Democrat who who's an
anti-backser and I bet we can get him to
challenge Joe Biden which was really
stupid and again it's it's it's because
they really aren't good at politics
they're just Trump and Trump allies are
not good at politics if if anything
Kevin McCarthy Kevin McCarthy having to
vacate his seat today at 1 30 I think 1
30 Eastern
um so we're we're I think the vote is
probably going on right now it might be
we're going to check in on it uh here
soon but that's I I got some business to
take care first of all Texas poem I am
really mad at you for offending [__]
sticks like that you call you call Steve
Bannon scabby mcfuckstick that is an
insult that is an insult to [__] sticks
everywhere okay first off I gotta take
care of that piece of business is that
is that is ridiculous that you would put
[__] sticks in that kind of category but
the other thing too is I got a birthday
here uh Suzanne happy birthday to you
I'm so happy that you're here with us on
your birthday thanks for being in chat
give give Suzanne a happy Birthday
everyone um but I want to go to a story
here while we're I'm gonna keep an eye
on the house floor here but I want to go
to the story speaking of right Wingers
and Nazis this is some wild [__]
um Ben Collins he's a reporter with NBC
News he's uncovered something really
weird about Elon Musk and Twitter uh Ben
tweeted this video earlier now he's
getting throttled heavily on Twitter
because of this video because of what
he's unearthing here he was on Rachel
maddow's show last night and I'm not
going to show the whole clip but I'll
show part of that one but I want to show
his video here on Twitter he says what's
going on with Elon Musk and why is he
doing this to Twitter I spent the last
few months digging into it I found a
pretty big clue uh so we're going to
watch this clip here of Ben Collins
telling us about the clue he hasn't
figured out who who texts the clue to
Elon Musk but let's let's watch Ben's
video
hey everybody so
um I spent the last few months trying to
figure out why Elon Musk is doing what
he's doing to Twitter and I think I
finally found a clue
this article here it's called The Battle
of the century here's what happens if
Elon Musk buys Twitter
and it outlines almost exactly what it
would do over the next year it tells him
to buy the company outright which he
does tells him to blame the ADL once
advertisers start fleeing
it is pretty pressuring and it also says
musk buying Twitter would be the
declaration of war against the globalist
American Empire
now how do I know that Elon Musk saw
this article it's because it was texted
to him 10 days before he bought the
company so I hired a very authoritative
sounding British guy to read those texts
to you congratulations the above article
was laying out some of the things that
might happen step one blame the platform
for its uses Step 2 coordinated pressure
campaign step 3 Exodus of the blue
checks step 4 the platform that it will
not be easy it will be a war let the
battle begin so here's why it's
important to find out who sent that text
to Elon it's because this blog is run by
a guy named Darren Beatty used to be a
trump Administration official
speechwriter who is fired for appearing
on a panel alongside White nationalists
now Laura kalobny my colleague and I
spent about nine months trying to get
the sender of that text unsealed
those texts appear in a lawsuit from
when Elon Musk tried to back out of
buying Twitter when we got more texts
unsealed the senders of those texts
unsealed this one was still redacted so
we really want to find out who sent that
text and there are people in the world
who have an unredacted version of that
document
are one of those people we probably know
who you are so please reach out to us so
we can solve this mystery so let's help
Ben solve this mystery because I think
if we know who text Elon Musk I think we
know the motivations behind uh why Elon
Musk is doing what he's doing on Twitter
what's your thoughts on this I'm going
to play the um
a little bit of the interview last night
with Rachel Mano but give me what you
think about what Ben is uncovered here
is this just a conspiracy theory tin
ball hand type [__] or do you think this
is something that actually has has been
used by Elon Musk and to put into action
to destroy Twitter and not only destroy
it but basically make it um a Nazi Haven
I mean that's essentially what it is
when you when you're just blaming the
ADL
yeah no this is absolutely 100 that's
why I've been screaming about the 2025
project this is this I'll tell you who's
redacted Leonard Leo that's who's
redacted this is from Leonard Leo they
have been putting this plan together for
years they have been planning to take
our country fascist four years and they
have the billionaires behind them to
fund it and this is absolutely part of
it you have the the Saudis which are not
our friends you know everybody's think
oh look how look how uh the Saudis are
becoming more Progressive they're not
killing women for driving now you know
no no the Saudis made a decision a long
time ago they've got billions of dollars
laying around if you think Idle Hands
Are The Devil's play toy let me tell you
Saudi billions laying around are the
devil's play toy these people are the
freaking devil and they are using their
billions to fund people like Leonard Leo
and to absolutely we bring fascism into
our country and they have these plants
folks you can read they'll tell you they
don't hide them you can read the 2025
project for yourself
well we're gonna go we're gonna go
through that more and more as the years
takes on with the project 2025 uh for
sure uh here on the Tony Michaels
podcast we're going to do a lot with
that but here is
um breaking it down because it's a huge
document it's 900 pages of how to turn
American uh into a fascist state but
here's the report last night with Rachel
Maddow and a little bit of uh Ben on her
show last night let's listen to this in
in 2018
CNN reported that a speechwriter in the
Trump White House had spoken at a white
nationalist conference and done a panel
with the founder of V dare and when that
news came out in CNN that speechwriter
was fired from the Trump white house but
these guys have to land somewhere right
turns out that guy who went straight
from appearing with the V dare guy at
the white nationalist event the week of
the 2016 election he went you know
straight from there to a job working in
the Trump White House as a speechwriter
thereafter when he was fired from even
the Trump White House he first briefly
landed a new speechwriter job with
Congressman Matt Gates then he lands at
a website a right-wing website that
among other things pushes the conspiracy
theory that there wasn't really an
attack on the U.S Capitol by a trump
supporting mob on January 6 2021 that
was actually an FBI operation well now
NBC news reports just within the last
hour
that it is that guy's far right website
that appears to have published the
blueprint
for right-wing billionaire Elon Musk to
buy these social media platform formerly
known as Twitter
to take it private and then to basically
kill it off last week we learned that
the new owner of Twitter just
unexpectedly cut half of the election
Integrity team at the company including
the guy who just a month before said the
company was hiring for that department
Mr musk is not just reinstated accounts
that had been banned for harassment or
or misinformation or inciting violence
he's also taken some weird terms like
when he started blaming the Jewish Civil
Rights group the Anti-Defamation League
for Twitter's Financial failings
is new tonight from Ben Collins of NBC
News he writes quote on the day that
public records revealed that Elon Musk
had become Twitter's biggest shareholder
an unknown sender texted the billionaire
and recommended an article imploring him
to acquire the social media outright
musk's purchase of Twitter the 3000 word
anonymous article said would amount to a
declaration of war against the globalist
American Empire the center of the text
was offering the Tesla and SpaceX CEO A
playbook for the Takeover and
transformation of Twitter as the
anniversary of musk's purchase of the
platform approaches the identity of the
sender remains unknown the three texts
were sent on April 4th 2022 in the
nearly 18 months since many of the
decisions made by musk after buying
Twitter appear to have closely followed
that road map up to and including his
ongoing attacks against the
Anti-Defamation League a non-profit
organization founded by Jewish Americans
to counter discrimination the article
recommended to Moscow published with no
byline on a site run by a far-right
blogger and former Trump White House
speechwriter who was fired in 2018 for
speaking on a panel alongside White
nationalists asked by NBC News if he
knew who sent the text to musk and who
wrote the article that musk was had
recommended to him the former Trump
speechwriter declined to comment well I
think I'm familiar with it but I'm not
in a position to comment on that the man
said quote I wish I could give you
something else
but you should look into the ADL most
uh Texas fall I mean obviously we know
exactly what this is this is Nazis
trying to get Elon Musk to turn Twitter
into a Nazi space and a Nazi uh safe
space which I I don't actually think is
going to be accomplished here I I
actually think that
either either Twitter will die or it
will be exposed but let's let Ben expose
it just a bit here for us go ahead go
ahead go ahead
I said Leonard Leo was with the Heritage
Foundation I might say Leonard Leo with
the Federalist Society yes my bad I just
misspoke myself
Federal Society Heritage Foundation
their cousins in fascism so you know
um yeah pretty close let's watch Ben
expose a little bit here uh about this
plan and Elon Musk and what how he's
laying it out of these texts in that
Discovery process were publicly known
who sent them for example Richard
Spencer the white Nash list his name is
in this trench of documents
um it's it's a it's a long laundry list
of people including like an Infowars
host who are in these documents but okay
so for people who don't know who Richard
Spencer is he's in he's a Nazi he's a
Neo-Nazi he's actually one of the
organizers of the Charlottesville uh uh
uh what do you call it the
Charlottesville and United right right
the unite the right
um that was his that was his little Nazi
thing him and David do but let's
continue
uh for some reason
um despite a nine-month fight with the
Delaware transfer court that me and my
colleague Laura collodany at CNBC went
through uh we still cannot figure out
who sent this text message
um and it sort of laid out a series of
of of
a things that he should do but also ways
in which people would react uh once he
did those things kind of laying out the
way that Twitter has has collapsed and
turned very very right way yeah this
this blog outlines exactly what would
happen for the next 18 months basically
he says you should invite back on all
the far-right users that might chase
away most users most people from this
website that you now own that you paid
for
um but it's worth it for the project and
by the way you're going to lose all your
advertisers he says this outright but
then he says
I have a plan for that you should blame
the ADL which uh to most people would
come out of left field in the last few
weeks like why is Elon Musk so angry at
the ADL but in this sphere and what I
would call the Bannon sphere
um this is where Darren Beatty sort of
lives the ADL is a common enemy and
Darren Beatty went on after after this
was published on his blog he went on
Tucker Carlson's website and basically
recited the stuff oh sorry on Tucker
Carlson's show which no longer exists
and uh basically recited this stuff uh
one to one so I don't know exactly where
Elon Musk saw this stuff probably when
he was texted it
um but it is pretty clearly A playbook
um that Elon Musk either ran directly
parallel to or read from himself
uh so there it is now I I know what it
is about the ADL that they don't like
I know what it is and it's obvious
they they're Nazis and I don't know if
people know about Nazis but part of the
tenement of fascism especially Nazis
is that they want to have a Jewish
genocide they want to exterminate Jewish
people from the planet among other
groups of people but Jewish people in
particular and the ADL is an
organization that is designed to combat
discrimination against Jewish people
um so it's not surprising that the ADL
is the natural enemy of Nazis and why
and why Nazis would blame them for this
stuff
um and if you're not aware of this I
just wanted to bring the audience uh
this to their attention mainly
um because of what you see on Twitter is
exactly what you think it is the reason
why he's allowing Nazis on Twitter is
because of this I want to point out
something here
um in in my personal experience of
someone who I've talked with personally
in a Twitter space uh soliman is [__]
ass wipe
um here he is defending Nick Fuentes for
not being on the Twitter platform
so uh Solomon if you guys don't know he
loves Andrew Tate he's an Andrew Tate
apologist he loves sex traffickers
apparently accused sex traffickers he
loves them Solomon does now he says Nick
Fuentes double standards on Twitter some
are boosted others are banned uh we are
aware that Nick Fuentes has been
completely banned and censored on
Twitter he was among the list of six
names provided to Twitter by the ADL
demanding which individuals should be
banned again and it goes on to say so
Nick Fuentes is banned because zionists
have concerns about his ideology while
Golding is promoting uh promoted despite
targeting Muslims where's the
consistency so again they're using what
about ISM and the attack on the ADL here
uh and if you don't know
Elon Musk has actually promoted on
Twitter some of the spaces that I've
that I've been in with Solomon and uh
Mario uh and and a lot of people are
accusing Mario being a fraud
um and soliman is definitely a piece of
trash uh I don't know if you guys know
that but I'm here to tell you I've
spoken with him he called me his boy
Texas bar on one of the spaces I said no
no no don't call me your [__] boy I'm
not your [__] boy I'm not your
[__] boy
um so Solomon dude honestly I can see
what you're doing and I know you're
probably you're probably either talking
directly to or uh with people in between
to Elon Musk and I see what you're doing
I want to show you a clip here uh that
right wing watch just posted recent go
ahead and go ahead talking about Solomon
I want to just give the audience uh some
advice after the show's over go do a
Google search for relations between Nazi
Germany
and the Arab world
and then read the Wikipedia article on
it it's just a Cliff's Notes version of
the history between the ties of the Arab
world and Nazi Germany
and the freaking Saudis are right in the
middle of it that the house of Saud has
has been allied with Nazis forever I
mean because they're fascist they're
fascist
and they hate Jewish people right
they're you know they're they're just do
yourself that favor so here's go read it
here's a clip of Nick Fuentes the person
that soliman it seems it's so unfair
that he's not let on Twitter and he's
blaming the ADL for it just like the
plan lays out listen to Nick Fuentes
here we played him on the show but
listen to what he said all the great
words of encouragement he has to say
here and see if you can figure out why
Suleiman wants him back on Twitter we
need people that really know the score
and we need people that have this
zealotry we need like jihadists and I
don't mean G I don't mean like suicide
bombers you know I don't mean like
violence but I need we need people that
are like insane we need like Joker level
like that kind of fanaticism
I'm like Bane and we need people that
are gonna say you know hey
they're gonna expect one of us in the
wreckage and we need people to say hey
well we started the fire that's okay we
need that kind of fanaticism
where's like the Nazi AOC not literally
but where where is like the fascist AOC
where's the right-wing Republican young
handsome congressman who is going to dog
whistle to the fascists and the Catholic
integralists and the wns
there you go
he says it he kills you he's telling you
what they are like they're embracing it
now I say they're Nazis and people like
oh you're going You're so out of you're
so out of turn I'm like why what the
[__] are you talking about they're
listening to these [__] boxes that are
calling themselves fascists they're
Nazis they're [__] Nazis and
Republicans out there who are voting for
republicans and people out there who are
elected Republicans may not think
they're Nazis but the Nazis think
they're Nazis okay they and if they
don't think they're Nazis they think
they're tools for their for their Nazi
rise to power folks which makes them
Nazis not anti-fascist it makes them
fascists and Nazis that is the key and
you know when when he's saying that
where's our young handsome Nazis you
know who's saying I'll be your
Huckleberry Josh Hawley that's right man
Josh Ollie is
I'm gonna get Lucas Koontz on the show
here soon uh and speaking of on the show
here soon we're soon to be over it we
have reached the top of the second hour
already I wish I would have been able to
show you more clips of of Grandpa poopy
pants absolutely making a fool of
himself in the Civil Right talk so much
but you know well you know I wanted to
make sure that we hammered out the house
and who the speaker was gonna be I
wanted to make sure we got to the
Twitter but there is one more thing that
I want to to show you guys before we go
it is very important that we not show
this on the internet today this is a
shot from behind Grandpa poopy pants
yesterday
um God damn what in the actual [__] is
going on with this guy why didn't he
just shave his head we all know he's
bald I called it a tumbleweed earlier
this this looks like this guy has three
[__] hairs that he ramps around that
bald Dome of his looks like a tumbleweed
what the [__] I couldn't go without
showing that pink
Daddy
he needs to be wearing a hat doesn't he
uh Texas Paul I'm so glad you're back
here on Tuesdays it's so great to have
you everyone uh Gabe Sanchez is going to
be up right after this oh here he is
here he is here's Jameson I was
wondering why why is it following you
what the hell is going on with your oh
oh hold on one sec one second oh we
ain't got one sec you gotta show it's
because it's because I'm on my I'm on my
camera that's why oh okay well you gotta
do it's on auto you got two minutes you
got two minutes go over there and get
ready audience be ready Gabe Sanchez
what was that live right after this
right after we're done here get the hell
out of here go to your show go to your
show go to your show would you please
all right everyone stick around as soon
as it's over make sure you subscribe
here on YouTube if you're not subscribed
already go to Facebook and follow us on
Facebook you can also make sure to
follow us on Twitch it's free make sure
to tie your your Prime account to your
Twitch account give us that one free
subscription go to realtexaspaul.com the
link is down below in the [__]
description real
texaspaul.com he's going to show her
tomorrow morning before my show we're
gonna throw to Gabe Sanchez here in just
a moment don't go anywhere if you're on
YouTube or on Twitch you're gonna get
directed directly to what was that live
with Gabe Sanchez same time same place
tomorrow
Surf's Up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] em [__] em
[Music]
y's meal Barn head ass Beacon